um let's speak to our correspondent in
the occupied West Bank at least three
Palestinians have been killed there
during Israeli raids overnight let's
speak to Imran Khan he's in rala Imran
the death toll there has been mounting
over the course of the last few weeks
talk us about what happened in these
latest
trades well the latest death Hall I can
bring you from the occupied West Bank is
114 three of those were killed last
night in the ascar refugee camp a
25-year-old Palestinian was killed and
10 others they wounded in the town of
tun which is in tubas a 32-year-old
Palestinian was killed there and seven
others were injured and in Betha near
rala a 30-year-old Palestinian was
killed so that's bringing the death tole
up to 114 like I say this is what we are
now seeing within the occupied West Bank
it used to be that the Israelis would
come into one location pretty much and
raid that location and come back it's
now multiple locations uh and multiple
targets it's happening almost every
single night certainly every single
night in the last seven days um every
time uh Palestinian goes to sleep now
they are worried that there is going to
be a raid somewhere near them and that's
what we're
seeing uh Imran we know that we've also
been talking about the number of
Palestinian prisoners in Israeli jails
for some time that's certainly being
discussed in Israel's negotiations with
Hamas I
imagine that's how absolutely right let
me just give you some numbers uh there
are some
6,600 uh Palestinians in Israeli jails
that's the highest number it's been in
over a decade um of those um 1,500 have
been actually arrested since October the
7th of the 6,600 1,800 are held without
charge on something that they call
administrative detention so the focus
for Hamas is getting their people out
getting these pal Palestinians out of
Israeli jail but that's something that
the Israelis are are bulking out because
they feel that their people in Gaza are
actually innocent and they are uh held
as hostages rather than uh prisoners or
captives but they see uh the
Palestinians that they're holding even
though they're holding many without
charge like I say as being part of the
prison system remember the occupied West
Bank doesn't come under Israeli civil
law it comes under Israeli military law
the occup
law so a lot of those uh people are held
on charges that perhaps wouldn't be held
in Israel minor charges perhaps for like
holding a Palestinian flag or even uh
picking up a rock at a demonstration
that kind of thing so it's a very
difficult negotiation process for the
Israelis but the Hamas are very clear uh
they want those Palestinian prisoners
out of jail Imran Khan there with the
latest for us from rala in the occupied
West Bank thank you Imran